the gyro can experience but it's also at
night there's something about the
darkness where I'm like I just you know
and I do a lot of my really [ __ ] up
thinking and everyone else in my house
is asleep yeah you know really yeah
that's when I that's when I spark up
that's when I write my best [ __ ] to it
was when everyone's asleep yeah be so
when everyone's asleep
I'm sitting around thinking like man
what if this keeps going sideways what
if we get a solar flare what if the grid
goes down what if the earthquake hits
what if the [ __ ] volcano under
Yellowstone blows what if this what if
asteroid hits what if a worse disease
catches on what if there's a war between
US and China over this [ __ ] there's
a crazy letter that Germany wrote to
China yesterday crazy the head of
Germany wrote some letter directly to
the head guy in China talking about the
only reason why you're in power is
because of surveillance and what have
you done to the world like what you
don't you guys have done because you
because of your disgusting pride and
you've you've hidden the facts from
people you've tried to distort the
reality and because of that hundreds of
thousands of people are going to die it
was deep just reading this letter like
you never read a letter like that we're
a one world leader [ __ ] on another
world leader was it wasn't no wasn't
there a head guy in the oh the head guy
in Germany's a woman right Angela Merkel
right who is it editor of a prominent
German newspaper okay well whoever the
person is right okay yeah the articles
that's right it's correct you know
because they never they don't admit any
fault ever whenever anything goes wrong
they cover everything up and there's so
many people that criticize the
government in China they just wind up
getting ghosted they just disappear they
vanish yeah
they'd never hear from them again no no
one knows what to do I mean that's
that's how they run things over there
what scares me is that if we give in to
that kind of like they have apps on
their phone right now that give them a
social score you know so like if you
jaywalk you lose
points oh yeah I heard about yeah oh
yeah and a guy yeah some guy said his
social scores really bad in people it's
almost like Minority Report because
they're almost like mirror yeah yeah
like that it's it's scary you know if we
give into that kind of surveillance over
here there's a real dark end to all that
stuff there's a real dark end the the
bright side is like oh well maybe
everybody keep a [ __ ] together and be
nice or maybe the government will be
watching every goddamn thing you do all
day long and hold that over you and then
they'll use that in order to gain more
political power that's just as possible
and more likely well if they of your
social score is like manipulated or
wrong the downside is a lack of freedom
and that's the whole reason why the
United States is so innovative the whole
reason is is this this we have this
spirit over here this spirit of freedom
you know we can do more we can get more
[ __ ] done we can we can come up with
ideas we celebrate this sort of creative
the the sort of creative spirit that we
think of when we think of the United
States we think of freedom we think of
creativity there's so much innovation
done over here
the moment you start clamping down on
people and taking away freedom you're
also going to take away that creativity
you're also going to take away that
innovative thought mentality you're
gonna make people scared and you're
gonna do it just so that you can control
them and it's [ __ ] it's the worst like
one of the one of the things about the
United States that makes it so great is
that we have the ability to criticize
our government we have the ability to
talk [ __ ] and that keeps people in check
[Applause]